Joey talk appears in Cleveland Ohio with
my main [ __ ] savages here
we were you serious math flavor the
Lord's day early I'm at my favorite
store with my wife she's as irritated as
I am we ain't coming here for the cream
of broccoli soup
this beauty target it's the real deal
what's the problem money I said look at
this this is look at this
Charlie Wang it's a beautiful bad target
[ __ ] movement holes in disease
[Music]
it's a beautiful day it's I get hit
look at that [ __ ] monster from the
Black Lagoon face with the earrings
there's a fun-filled afternoon when I go
to the museum with the glasses you see
this the ymc [ __ ] a a blood drive you
[ __ ]
I'm coming over here to do a couple
jumping jacks and these [ __ ] people
taking blood up that's the last thing I
need but Mike Dolce put me to the
[ __ ] test
Brittney's [ __ ] math flavor here
of my boys
Joe Rogan Mike [ __ ] Dolce and red
band they put me on the Dolce challenge
salary pounds twenty thirty thirty
pounds and six [ __ ] months but to me
but to me but it's really about being
healthy so every week I'm gonna make a
little YouTube video for Mike and show
them that I'm working out yeah it's
beautiful all right now as you know I
could sue on it we start we start the
revolution I'm gonna be [ __ ] joke that
[ __ ] and now I got to do what I got to
do [ __ ] it they've taken my blood out
I'll see you guys in there stay black
math lately my vultures probably
treadmills rice Meghan stay part
leaving the YMCA dulce style drenched in
the [ __ ] gills I'm still a fat [ __ ]
I'll Eastwood together on this you're
with me I'm with you and they're with
[ __ ] us you follow me mad flavor
thank you for paying attention all the
way down to 270 [ __ ] and when I'm not
in the Y I'm at the beautiful North
Hollywood [ __ ] Park right there check
it out North Hollywood partly the size
that we're gonna start meeting there on
Saturdays and do [ __ ] smoke outs and
walkathons for all you fat [ __ ] in the
valley in Northern California will have
at whatever the [ __ ] it is I don't know
still a target trying to get some cat
cats them look at this Eddie Munster
look at [ __ ] over here check
and there's the other way is [ __ ]
dude I've ever seen in all that
with a [ __ ] pink shirt on he couldn't
stick out more what's he think I'm
looking he [ __ ] scares Halloween well
he got a little ugly [ __ ] what's this
with the picture unbelievable mad
flavors world
target the [ __ ] Adams family of
supermarkets and the fight become up
this Ohio is my man Brett man
he's
Oh miss Ohio is a building that has
the stuff
what's happened what's up in the doctor
I told you hey a.com hope you
these people don't believe me direct and
Cleveland are one of the biggest stone
is look at his eyes look that's what a
stoner should look like right there
that's a professional not some [ __ ]
mom oh my god [ __ ] if your eyes don't
look like that you're hanging out with
the wrong [ __ ] people you understand
me
your friends that's a positive
[ __ ] right there come here oh
yeah if you can see he'll meet to see
he's [ __ ] stoned so get this if
you're not hired by two o'clock go [ __ ]
yourself
direct for me and my friends in
Cleveland you're dirty [ __ ]
where you going why are you leaving me
on here all alone by myself at Target
come on let's go you got me in these
horrible always I'm trying to make my
shirt target documentary on the Lord's
Day and look how you're treating you
know I'm suddenly this poor soul
[Music]
un-fuckin'-believable the things you see
when I ain't got us up machine gun in
him samples he threw this pool and he
knew his dress
all right
[Music]
[Music]
this lady with the pink hang out by the
Chiefs view away from the cheese
[ __ ] get that
there's no way today
stay black that flavors book
[Music]